G
AN OPEN LOOK.
HOW DID IT LOOK AFTER THE SECOND
HAVE COME BACK?
>> FIRST OF ALL, -- I THINK I
NEED TO POKE LEBRON IN HIS EYE A
LOT MORE FOR HIS SHOTS LIKE
THAT.
HE HAS DONE IT HIS WHOLE CAREER,
ALWAYS HITTING FROM THAT TYPE OF
RANGE.
BIG SHOT, PUT US UP THREE.
THE DEFENSE TOWARDS THE END,
KNOWING THEY ARE DOWN THREE, AND
STEPH WILL BE THE GUY TO SHOOT
IT, WE SMOTHERED HIM.
THAT IS THE TYPE OF DEFENSE WE
HAVE TO DO.
ESPECIALLY IN THE SECOND HALF.
FIRST HALF, VERY LACKS A DAYS
AGO AND NOT OUR BEST TYPE OF
DEFENSE.
BUT WE PICKED IT UP IN THE
SECOND HALF.
WE KEPT GOING AND KEPT PLAYING.
WE KNEW IT WOULD NOT BE PERFECT
AGAINST REPORTER: WHAT DID YOU F
LEBRON'S GAME-WINNING THREE?
YOU NORMALLY SINK THOSE SHOTS.
STEVE: IT WAS A GREAT SHOT.
BROKEN PLAY.
I SUNK IN, THINKING HE WAS KIND
OF OUT OF THE PLAY, THEY FOUND
HIM, HE GOT HIS BALANCE JUST IN
TIME AND KNOCKED IT DOWN.
THAT WAS A TOUGH ONE BECAUSE YOU
DON'T REALLY EXPECT IT TO GO
AND, YOU EXPECT US TO GET THE
REBOUND, GO DOWN IN TRANSITION,
HAVE A POSITION.
EVERYTHING CHANGES WHEN IT GOES
IN.
ALL-TIME GRE